جنوبيون من القرى الحدوديه اجبرتهم
الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه على ترك ارضهم بعد
ما اصبحوا عرضه للقذف والغارات وجهتهم
الاقرب مدينه صور على الساحل
الجنوبي الى هنا نزحت الحاجه سهام عائلتها
من بلده بيت ليف مراره النزوح وصعوبته كما
تقول ارحم من العيش تحت القصف الاسرائيلي
الذي ارعب
احفادها نحنا عننا بيوت عننا رازق عننا
زيتون كله تركني وظهرنا النا 70 نهار
ظاهرين ما بدي احاربه وارجع على بيتي لو
كان مهدم بتمنى اعمل خيمه واقعد
ببيتي ما تتمناه سهام يعاكسه الميدان فمع
اشتداد القصف الاسرائيلي واتساع رقعته
جغرافيا تزايدت اعداد النازحين الالاف
هجروا قراهم ونزح الى بلدات بعيده عن
الحدود وصولا الى العاصمه ومناطق اخرى
اعداد تضاعفت معها التحديات في ظل
الامكانيات المحدوده للسلطات اللبنانيه
البرد عم بزيد كثير عليهم في ناس كثير ما
ماد عم تلاقي لا غرف ولا اماكن للايجار
لحتى تقعد فيها او انه بيوت تستضيفها في
بعض البلديات بلغتنا انه ماش فيها تستقبل
نازحين الصفارات لا تكاد تهدا في هذا
المركز مهت الاخلاء والانقاذ متواصله ليل
نهار فالاستخدام الاسرائيلي للمدنيين
وبيوتهم بات شبه يومي نحن اليوم بحرب حرب
مع دو اسرائيلي التحديات انه نحن عم نطلع
على الممات على الضيع ما بعرف شو مخبي لنا
ما بنعرف ايمت بينزل قصف علينا ما بنعرف
ايمتى بنضرب بلغ القصف الاسرائيلي مرات
عده محيطه هذه المدينه وبلدات في عمق
محافظه جنوب لبنان التي لجا اليها
النازحون لكنها رغم ذلك ما زالت تشكل
مناطق امنه نسبيا مقارنه ببلدات الشريط
الحدودي حيث حل الدمار وغابت او تكاد كل
مظاهر
الحياه لم تبقي المقاتلات والمسيرات
الاسرائيليه اي بقعه امنه هنا عند الخط
الامامي من الحدود منازل مدمره واراض
محروقه ومدارس ومستشفيات مهجوره ويخشى
ابناء هذه القرى ان لا تعود حياتهم قريبا
الى ما كانت عليه وهم الذين اختبروا وطاه
الاحتلال واستهدافه المتكرره للمدنيين
طيله عقود كترين حنا الجزيره جنوبيه لبنان